we have to start today with something so
important and of such consequence but
which regularly generates almost no
interest from our audience which is
foreign policy and what's going on right
now with russia and ukraine as we've
been covering and as many of you
uh have been seeing on a variety of
different media outlets
russia has been massing troops at the
border with ukraine now even that
statement is questioned by some who want
to defend putin
or
claim that that's all a lie for the
purposes of furthering american
imperialism or whatever um we're going
to have a real hard time having any
conversation if we can't even agree on
the the fundamentals but that's going on
and now the discussion is among the
united states as well as other nato
allies
about if when and how
to mobilize military resources to nato
allies surrounding ukraine remembering
that ukraine is not part of nato and
that's a piece of this as well
with the question of
what would happen with those troops if
indeed russia did push into ukraine and
what would be russia's reason for doing
so when does vladimir putin really plan
to do that or is he only making it
appear as though he might plan to do
that so the latest news is that the
pentagon has put 8 500 troops on what
they are calling heightened alert
and that um joe biden was presented with
a number of options including moving
troops and equipment from other parts of
europe into poland romania and other
neighboring countries to ukraine again
remembering that ukraine itself is not a
nato ally the u.s is discussing the
deployment of military forces to eastern
europe with nato allies lloyd austin has
played placed 8 500 troops on heightened
alert to assist with the defense of nato
allies we have a clip of that uh here is
john kirby the spokesperson from the
pentagon
i want to provide some facts on these
preparations that will reinforce our
commitment to nato and to the nato
response force and increase our
readiness
secretary austin has placed a range of
units in the united states on a
heightened preparedness to deploy which
increases our readiness to provide
forces if nato should activate the nrf
or if other situations develop
all told
the number of forces that the secretary
has placed on heightened alert
comes up to about 8 500 personnel
so we don't know what's going to happen
yet there are all sorts of different
speculations which quite frankly aren't
super interesting to me because we just
don't know what vladimir putin is
thinking but one of the most interesting
aspects of this is how different
political factions in the u.s have
responded as many of you now probably
know
on the
trump right
there is indeed
a pro-putin pro-russia
wing
which
developed under trump and it came in
part from trump's sort of deference to
vladimir putin for lack of a better term
not saying putin is a puppet master of
trump in any uh direct way i'm not
saying they colluded together to figure
you don't have to believe any of that
stuff that that's not what i'm saying
trump has been enamored with strongman
authoritarian dictator types he talked
about how he and kim jong-un fell in
love i might even have that clip we fell
in love
and then we fell in love exactly
um you guys know all this stuff and to
that end
um we have seen a lot of these trumpists
kind of become enamored similarly with
putin and russia
similarly there are some on the left
what i tend to call
here we go the revolutionary left
the stalinist leninist
left and that's l-e-n-i-n by the way
some of you write to me and spell lennon
like john lennon and i'm wondering like
who do these who do they think i'm
referring to when i say leninist anyway
uh there's some there as well
who have become very deferential to
russia usually they are sort of pro
chavez maduro types often they like
fidel castro
uh sometimes their views on syria are
sort of strange so there's that group as
well but one of the really interesting
things is that there's kind of a factual
firewall that seems to be plaguing some
where yesterday i saw for example
why is it
that tucker saying we should be loyal to
russia is not okay
but democrats saying we should be loyal
to ukraine is okay like either way
you're just kind of picking aside and of
course i'm not picking any sides i'm
against aggression
and i'm against strongman authoritarians
in this particular case it's putin
massing the troops at the border with
ukraine it is not ukraine
massing troops at the border with russia
and
throwing signals as if they might invade
russia so you can have any analysis that
makes sense to you
you can have a particular predilection
for russia or ukraine and quite frankly
i i don't
but to say it's sort of the same when
one side clearly is the one at least
feigning aggression if not actually
planning to carry it out is not a very
sensible analysis so now there's going
to be some wait and see
and if anybody is going to write in and
say david you imperialist bastard
wanting u.s i don't want
any aggression i don't want any invasion
i don't want any war
i don't want troop deployment i don't i
don't want any of it i i think it's all
bad and it and i'm selfishly of that
opinion
i want stable economies what's happening
in the stock market almost daily is not
pleasing to me and i think it would only
get worse if these escalations were so
i'm against all of it i don't want the
us invading anybody or anything like
that now once you understand the
dynamics of ukraine not even being in
nato and the discussion with biden and
nato allies is about the defense of nato
allies in the area
you understand that that conversation
isn't even the appropriate one to be
having but that's what's going on we may
know more within a day
we may know more within
weeks could be months we just don't know
major legal news out of the state of
georgia
a grand jury has been approved to
investigate donald trump's election
interference remember those 11 000 votes
he wanted i need 11 000 votes give me a
break yeah it turns out crimes may have
been committed there and we may soon see
the difference in power between a
congressional subpoena and your regular
good old-fashioned
district court grand jury subpoena cnn
reporting d.a for atlanta area granted
special grand jury to probe trump's
election interference this is not good
news for the former president
the article reads an atlanta area
district attorney investigating former
president donald trump's efforts to
overturn the 2020 results in georgia
will be allowed to seat a special grand
jury this spring
fulton county d.a fanny willis requested
last week to seat a special grand jury
starting may 2nd some are saying that's
ambitious date but we'll see fulton
county superior court judges approved
the request on monday though the special
grand jury does not have the authority
to issue an indictment the move will
allow willis to seat a panel
exclusively focused on gathering
evidence in the trump investigation she
said she needed such a grand jury in
order to issue subpoenas to compel
witnesses to testify and gather evidence
a step toward pursuing possible criminal
charges understand this is all under the
umbrella of criminality
willis said she expects to decide
whether to bring charges against trump
in the first half of 2022 which gives us
that that self-imposed deadline is june
30th now can you do that between may 2nd
and june 30th you can legal analyses
i've read say you can but it is it is
certainly aggressive
willis wrote last week that her office
received information indicating a
reasonable probability that the state of
georgia's administration of elections in
2020 including the state's election of
president of the u.s was subject to
possible criminal disruptions this is
very very real and very very serious
this is going to give the d.a fannie
willis the power to file criminal
subpoenas these are much more difficult
to delay or to avoid
than the congressional subpoenas that
we've been seeing under the umbrella of
the trump riot investigation
as far as she believes
she has enough materials to suggest
crimes were committed
and in
in theory at least depending on if and
what donald trump comes up with if the
situation surfaces she could compel
testimony to the grand jury
to
further
the
belief that criminality took place now
grand juries in georgia have some
interesting rules the accused in georgia
does not have a right to appear before a
grand jury they don't have a right to
have their attorney appear before a
grand jury they don't have the right to
present witnesses or cross-examine
witnesses if you are accused and a grand
jury is investigating you in georgia um
you are not it is not a criminal trial
with all of the rights that come as a
defendant in a criminal trial
you can
testify or refuse to testify in
accordance with a fifth amendment
invocation and
the u.s judicial system considers lying
to a grand jury
very very serious
and this is very quickly having the
potential to become a serious criminal
matter for donald trump now let's talk
about the timeline a little bit like i
said may 2nd is when the grand jury is
expected or planned to be impaneled and
they are saying they want to make
decisions about whether or not to charge
donald trump criminally if that is
indeed the person that becomes the focus
by the um during the first half of the
year which is june 30th so you're
basically talking about two months can a
grand jury
uh really do everything it needs to do
to allow the da to make a charging
decision in just two months
again
in in reading opinions from legal
analysts on this
it is possible
but there are
legal
analysts who believe it is far more
likely that the charging decision would
come closer to the november elections
now i'm not even
imagining
what the repercussions of that may be
because there's still a lot of things
that have to happen between now and then
but this is step one step one is
you get the go-ahead for the grand jury
you start sending out subpoenas you see
who shows up and then you go from there
so
might not be disastrous for donald trump
he does seem to be quite teflon when it
comes to anything that looks at him
personally
but if you're trump
you would have preferred the grand jury
be rejected rather than approved and
that's where we are right now it has
been approved let me know what if
anything you believe will come from this
you can find me on twitter at d pacman
send me your thoughts we'll take a very
quick break and be right back
don't forget that the best way to
support the david pakman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the daily bonus show the regular show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire archive of every episode
dating back
a really long time and plenty of other
awesome membership perks go to
joinpackman.com
and use the coupon code better21 for a
huge discount join pacman.com
as an independently run progressive
media show we do depend on people from
our audience to support the work that we
do and the easiest way to do that the
quickest way to do that and the most
direct where the vast majority of every
dollar stays with us
is to get a membership at
joinpacman.com we do an extra show every
day for our members you also get
commercial free audio and video feeds of
the show and you get the show every day
six hours earlier than we release it
publicly six hours earlier that's a big
deal you can sign up at joinpackman.com
you can also
use the coupon code wow 22
to save off of the price of a membership
if you so please pay full price or not
we just want as many people involved and
supporting as possible and you can sign
up at joinpakman.com all right let's
talk about something very very
disturbing
um
not that joe biden called the reporter a
son of a [ __ ] we'll get to that we'll
get to that but i'm finding that to be
in poor taste but not actually scary and
disturbing the following is scary and
disturbing
republicans are now openly saying
openly saying
if they win the house of representatives
in november and take control in january
of 2023
they will look to subpoena
potentially prosecute and maybe imprison
members of congress participating in the
january 6th committee investigating the
trump riots of last year
when they say this stuff we should take
them seriously rather than saying
no
when they told us what they were
planning for the 2020 presidential they
did it we should have taken it more
seriously and we should be taking this
more seriously now so i'm going to play
a clip for you of newt gingrich newt
gingrich was the speaker of the house in
1994 ushered in significant acceleration
in the republican party's abandonment of
policy and moving into cultural issues
and and the like we've talked about his
role uh in that significantly you can
check out my interview with noam chomsky
where we talk about newt gingrich's role
one of the things that we have heard
from republicans is that if they win the
house in 2022 they will impeach joe
biden and i believe that they certainly
will try
but here is something extraordinarily
dystopian from newt gingrich and again
just we have no reason to doubt him here
he is
uh you're going to have a republican
majority in the house and republican
majority in the senate and all these
people who've been so tough and so mean
and so nasty are going to be delivered
subpoenas for every document every
conversation every tweet every email
because i think it's clear that this
these are people who are literally just
running over the law
pursuing innocent people causing them to
spend thousands and thousands of dollars
in legal fees for no justification and
it's basically a lynch mob and
unfortunately the attorney general
united states has joined that lynch mob
and is totally misusing the fbi and i
think when you have a republican
congress this is all going to come
crashing down and the wolves are going
to find out that they're now sheep and
they're the ones who are in fact going
to i think face a real risk of jail for
the kind of laws they're breaking
participating in
the dually impaneled investigation
of one of the most disgusting events of
the last five years in the united states
if newt gingrich got his way and he's
not running but he's still a powerful
figure in the republican party
might put some of those investigators
in jail
folks when they tell you what they're
going to do or what they're going to try
to do
take them seriously that is a lesson
from the 2020 presidential election take
them seriously even republican
congresswoman liz cheney issued a
warning over this she retweeted the
gingrich video we just played and added
the comment quote a former speaker of
the house
is threatening jail time for members of
congress
who are investigating the violent
january 6 attack on our capital and our
constitution
this is what it looks like
when the rule of law unravels
now liz cheney is one of only two
republicans on that committee doing the
investigation so she may feel as though
she is now in the crosshairs and may
have a personal interest in this for
sure
but this is an idea that republicans are
liking here is video of matt gates
appearing on
real america's voice
war room this might even be his show i'm
so confused by this channel this may be
matt gates's own show listen to what he
had to say about it now you have the
january 6 event where i expect that
there will be these shadowy gray area
national security types that are in and
around the activation of the increase in
criminal acuity of that day and not for
nothing steve but using a cut out seems
like exactly what they were trying to do
to me now note this is all
conspiratorial type stuff about the
people doing the investigating or the
ones responsible for the right it's
crazy but let's continue to listen
because it tells us what a state of mind
is when it comes to this stuff
there's a guy named steve alford who's
sitting in prison right now for trying
to extort me but he was not acting alone
very likely he was answering to a cut
out someone like bob kent to try to
destroy me because you know what newt's
right we are going to take power and
when we do it's not going to be the days
of paul ryan and trey gowdy where the
republicans go limp wristed where they
lose their backbone and fail to send a
single subpoena limp wristed is that a
homophobic uh phrase i'm not super
familiar with it but it strikes me as
potentially homophobic let me know yeah
no it's going to be the days of jim
jordan and matt gates and marjorie
taylor green and you know what we're
going to get answers real answers about
what about what happened in the election
answers about the wuhan institute of
virology and certainly answers about a
department of justice and a national
security apparatus that has gone totally
off the rails they have become the
enforcement wing of the democratic party
the entire country knows it and you know
what we need honest fair real
application of the laws in our country
yeah we're not getting that now and
frankly we weren't really getting it at
the doj under president trump there's so
listen
you've got to take them seriously just
believe what they're telling you if
they're telling you they're going to do
this stuff then we have to listen and we
have to take it seriously because
they seem to really try to do it whether
they get away with it is a different
question you know they tried the 2020
stuff
when you look back and think about 20 20
20 they they tried every aspect of it
they tried the fake elector stuff
they tried pressuring local officials
they tried stopping the count versus
starting the count as convenient to them
uh they
at least it was in the conversation
about uh declaring a national emergency
slash martial law though they'll say
they weren't really close to doing it
which may be true but it was part of the
discussion we know that multiple people
have told us
they're telling us what they're going to
do and we have to take it really
seriously
they will try to jail their political
adversaries and they're admitting that
that's what they're going to try to do
and we've got to be really really
concerned about it and not let our guard
down in 2022 is particularly
consequential because of that
this is a crazy story out of australia
we have we have quite a quite a few
viewers in australia in fact it's one of
our outside of the u.s i mean it makes
sense it's a lot of english-speaking
countries canada the uk and australia
are where we have some of the biggest
audiences
and uh close to 10 people
sent me this story
about australian anti-vaxxers
completely fabricating the death of a
boy from sydney australia
supposedly from the coveted vaccine it
turns out it was completely made up this
is being reported by seven news in
australia as well as a number of other
media outlets a distraught sydney father
has shared how his beautiful
seven-year-old boy died in the back of
an ambulance days after be being
vaccinated against covid but authorities
say it's a hoax
in a lengthy facebook comment steve
leary claimed his son lachlan received
his first vaccine dose on wednesday is
that a popular australian name because
it does isn't one of rupert murdoch's
kids also named lachlan
um lachlan received his first dose on
january 12th experienced a fever and
difficulty br difficulty breathing
shortly after
he claims he took his son to west med
hospital where they ran tests and after
five hours sent him home
friday morning at 4am we heard him yell
out he was on his bedroom floor he then
collapsed he was not breathing wrote the
father
he claims his son died of a massive
heart attack and warns other parents not
to vaccinate the government has ruined
my family they have taken away our only
son i mean this this is tragic if true
the post quickly gathered pace online
collecting thousands of likes comments
and shares before the profile was taken
down and the post reshared as a
screenshot
but it's believed to be the latest case
of misinformation running rife a
deliberate attempt to discourage parents
booking in to get their children
vaccinated less than a week after five
to eleven-year-olds became eligible for
coveted vaccines in australia there is
no record of a lachlan leary who died in
sydney last week or indeed at all
uh
and nsw health told 7 news it quote has
not been able to locate any record of
such incident
and the therapeutic goods administration
which collates all adverse events
associated with vaccines also rubbished
the claim in a statement statement a
spokesperson stressed it has not
received any adverse event reports
involving the death of any children
between 5 and 11. the children's
hospital at westmead also refuted the
reports in writing saying there are many
inaccurate posts currently circulating
on social media there is no record of
any child having passed away following
covet vaccination at our hospital there
are also questions surrounding the
validity of mr leary's profile news of
the death pictured leary a man who lives
in the united states and served as the
mayor of winter park a small town in
florida
um
this is uh
this is this is really immoral
um and
everything we believe now
indicates that this is merely a hoax
meant to dissuade parents
from going and getting their kids
vaccinated against covet
we are fortunately seeing the decline of
omicron now in the united states case is
down about 21
as of this morning we are seeing a
leveling out globally
many
individual states in the us are down
significantly but
one of the groups that is most getting
seriously ill
uh on a rate basis
is the very young
most of whom have not yet been
vaccinated and this is again it's
another opportunity to move to the
endemic phase it endemic doesn't mean no
risk but it means something different
than pandemic
we have an opportunity part of it is
getting as many people protected from
getting seriously ill
you might catch it but you're much less
likely to be seriously ill five to 11
year olds are part of that and this
appears to be an out and out complete
and total hoax and i hope that at least
as far as the us is concerned this
reminds people when you hear about
vayer's reports where tens of thousands
of reports about kids dead from the
vaccine those reports are completely
unverified
anybody can go and submit a report to
vayers now people will write in they'll
say david it's it's a crime to do that
uh is anybody getting prosecuted for
that have you heard of anybody being
prosecuted for submitting a false report
to vayers that is not dissuading people
from doing it they are weaponizing the
vares report which is the vaccine
adverse effects reporting
system i assume the s's system
so an incredibly pernicious moment and
i am not advocating one way or the other
australia has different laws than the
united states it remains to be seen
whether this individual
may face
some kind of
penalty of course if he really lives in
the united states it's not really clear
that anything would apply but we're
going to follow the story that's
everything we know right now and we will
have a link to the story and more
information
on our instagram which you can find at
david pakman show
if you value what we do at the david
pakman show remember to support us on
patreon go to
patreon.com davidpakmanshow where you
can get access to behind the scenes
videos the daily bonus show the
commercial free daily show as well as
special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies mugs and t-shirts
you can support the show for as little
as two dollars a month check it out at
patreon.com david packman show today
we're going to be speaking with david
feidler who's a writer philosopher and
also author of the recently published
book breakfast with seneca a stoic guide
to the art of living which is a clear
and accurate guide to the teachings of
the stoic philosopher seneca david it's
really great having you on i appreciate
it hey it's uh great to speak with you
david so
particularly during the pandemic on
social media and elsewhere
stoicism as a philosophy has has become
very very much in vogue with a lot of
different people
posting everything from memes to
articles about it and often there's this
kind of very
top level understanding that
stoicism means showing little emotion
and just sort of being only
slightly connected to the world around
you which is not at all what the
philosophy advocates for so so maybe we
could start there with what what is the
the what is stoicism
right that's a really uh good starting
point and uh stoicism it's an ancient
greek and roman philosophy of life
but
the issue that you're alluding to is uh
the word stoic has actually changed to
mean something totally else over the
course of like many centuries the
philosophy itself is like
2 300 years old
and now
stoicism means to repress your emotions
or keep a stiff upper lip
and
that has nothing to do with the original
philosophy in fact
the stoics
were
uh not unemotional in any way they
experienced regular emotions and they
thought they were fine the only problem
that the stoics had was with extreme
negative emotions which they felt arose
from incorrect opinions and they saw
those extreme negative emotions as being
things like anger
worry
anxiety
and things like that
so how did someone like seneca
what framework did seneca advocate for
for dealing with those negative emotions
okay
um
one of the most central teachings of uh
stoicism this is something that all of
the roman stoics uh believed in
and this is probably a huge takeaway for
the people who are listening to this
discussion today is that
their idea was that we can't control
what actually happens to us but we can
control how we respond to things they
all believed in that
and
the main idea was that uh it's not
really things or events that upset us
but the opinions or judgments that we
hold about things and an example of this
that i use in the book is uh imagine
it's like raining and you're walking
along one day
and you walk by a big puddle and a car
comes by and splashes you and you're
covered with water well
someone might have the mental opinion
that well i just got splashed which is a
pretty objective way of looking at
things but another person might think oh
you've ruined my entire day and then
develop a sense of anger and rage about
that and then want to
get even with the driver in some way so
that shows how
the opinions that we hold about things
really uh influence our emotional states
or even act as the seed of these extreme
negative emotions and
uh this belief
it's not things or events that upset us
but the opinions we hold about things
that's the origin of what is now known
as cognitive therapy
or cognitive behavioral therapy and the
stoics really uh
invented cognitive therapy that's what
uh their theory of emotion was about and
the modern people the modern
psychologists who invented cognitive
therapy actually drew on these stoic
ideas and mentioned the stoics by name
yeah you know as i hear you talk about
it there's this book from the 20th
century by viktor frankl man's search
for meaning which i don't think is
overtly about stoicism but he lays out
in the context of surviving the
holocaust
a very similar idea about he could not
control his circumstances but he could
control
the reaction he had to those
circumstances which seems quite similar
exactly and
i think there's a very famous saying
attributed to him that uh
our freedom exists in the fact that
we're able to pause
before
we make a decision or a judgment and
that's really our source of freedom now
uh apparently he didn't say that he went
back to rallo may but the the thought is
the same and certainly his his idea uh
you know is an exact parallel to that of
the stoics
one of the kind of big
pushbacks and reactions i see to this
recent popularization of stoicism
are comments along the lines of yeah
that's really great to think about if
your basic needs are met and you have
time to hang out on social media or
reading books but if you're not sure
where your next meal is coming from or
you don't have housing or you need
health care and can't afford it
stoicism is not useful in that way and
it's another one of these sort of now
becoming commercialized ideas that
spread on social media
how would you react to that critique of
the popularization of stoicism um
well
i don't think that's really true because
now seneca actually was very wealthy uh
the the person the stoic philosopher i
wrote the book about he was actually one
of the wealthiest people in the roman
empire but the earlier greek stoics
weren't wealthy at all and uh the most
famous stoic to follow him
uh in rome was epictetus so epictetus
was maybe like about 15 when seneca died
and he was actually a slave
so it was a philosophy that uh was
embraced from slaves to roman emperors
and
certainly
all of
these stoic ideas are applicable
you know by anyone today it doesn't
matter on your level of wealth in fact
the stoics believed that our true goods
lie within us and they believe that you
know it's very valuable and it's an
advantage to have like wealth
uh
a beautiful family a beautiful house but
it's only our inner character that
allows us to uh use those things in a
good way
so for the stoics the most important
part of life was really developing a
good character and that's something they
would say holds true for everyone
with um if i recall correctly seneca had
some
uh
views on crowds and and mob mentality
that
seemed like they might be relevant today
to some degree including to to media and
sort of some of the other modern
things that humans today are presented
with can you talk a little bit about
that
uh sure uh actually uh seneca has the
story about how he went to see the
gladiatorial games and then
people were being killed in front of his
eyes and the crowd was cheering for the
death
of the gladiators
and
the other people that were thrown into
the ring and he was actually as far as i
can tell the first person to write about
what is now called a crowd or mob
psychology which was
a study that developed in like the
mid-1800s and
people now study things like emotional
contagions
uh
things like that and also how we
unconsciously
assimilate
the behavior of people that we're
exposed to
and this this holds very true in today's
uh
sort of like internet
uh world or twitter world where uh you
know you
get these uh emotional contagions that
seem to
uh that seem to float through the
internet and uh they're very contagious
because sometimes you'll see like a
video clip and you don't have the full
context of it and people are making
judgments about it and denouncing it and
things like that and it's very easy to
get swept up um in that kind of behavior
and seneca warned about that
specifically if he was alive today he
would say you know take a step back
and uh
don't assent
you know immediately to the the judgment
of the crowd or the mob but uh wait
until things become clarified and also
you know be mindful of due process as
well
uh you can't make those judgments just
based on a tweet
oftentimes usually you need further
information
um
what was uh you you write in the book
about
the
value of time
and of not
postponing what one wants to do sort of
indefinitely or i mean
maybe even to any degree beyond what
what's kind of logistically necessary
can you talk a little bit about that in
the connection to stoicism
right
well uh this is something that's really
specific to seneca he writes about this
a lot and he says that time is our most
valuable asset so
um people are very careful about the way
that they guard their wealth but when it
comes to guarding their time they don't
even think about it usually and
his idea is that people spend a lot of
time rushing around and acting as though
they're preoccupied with things whereas
it's it's more of an act sometimes and
he felt that
we should be very careful about the way
that we uh
use our time uh what i would say uh he
actually talks about for example like
how people
believe that
they'll someday retire
and they spend their entire life working
but then he says how do you know that
you'll live to be 50 or 60 years old you
could die at any moment and his his idea
was like finding some kind of balance
between work and leisure
and he would have agreed with the modern
idea that uh
we should work to live rather than live
to work
yeah that you know sometimes
you you you get these um
distortions i guess i would say
of some of these precepts and they are
sort of exaggerated and taken to the
extreme where like what you just said
would be taken to mean you know this
kind of you only live once
don't plan for the future at all kind of
mentality but really the it seems to me
the value in thinking about these things
is about finding some kind of balance
that that makes sense rather than
picking some extreme to adhere to
exactly and that's something that
everyone really has to deal with on
their own because everyone's life is
different so how
one person will find the kind of balance
between life and work will be different
than another person but it's certainly a
an important question to think about
going back a little bit to the social
contagion thing which you know we i you
explained and i think is really clear
when it comes to like stuff on the
internet as an example when you look at
the socio political system maybe
specifically in in the united states
what are some other areas in which this
social contagion is taking place that
would be interesting to to be aware of
well i think actually
one of the reasons that this has become
such a phenomenon is it's exacerbated by
the internet
and another aspect of it also is that
the the internet has been very good for
many things for example we can have
discussions like this but in other ways
i think it's been very very negative
because people base journalistic
coverage now on the number of clicks
that stories get so uh journalism has
become very click-baity and it's also
really harmed you know serious print
journalism so
uh basically
journalists and the media have every
every reason to encourage
people getting angry about things for
example because you know it's those
stories that make people angry
that uh usually have the highest uh you
know click-through rates
yeah and i mean we see that daily where
a story that we spend
a while researching about
to take today you know the build-up to
what's going on with russia and ukraine
right it just is not going to generate
even a fraction of the interest that joe
biden calling that fox reporter a son of
a [ __ ] yesterday is going to generate
and
if you ask me which is most
substantively valuable it's obviously
the geopolitical impact with historical
uh implications of the ukraine russia
thing but it's not it it
for all the reasons you're talking about
it's just not going to do as well
right
um you know another thing too is that
you have these huge media platforms now
and so they have a certain amount of
space allotted for you know the
so-called news so that if nothing's
happening they actually have to fill it
with something yes
yeah no that that's that's certainly an
issue as well um when it comes to uh
marcus aurelius is often sort of your
book focuses on seneca but you mentioned
seneca epictetus marcus elias kind of
the third in the maybe most three known
uh stoics
what
does his perspective did his perspective
differ in significant ways from that of
seneca
it's really interesting because when i
was researching the book i looked into
this in a great deal of depth
and it's surprising how
similar the views of the three main
roman stoics were
for example an average reader wouldn't
notice this but
all three of the roman stoics believed
that when you were on your deathbed
that you should feel a sense of
gratitude when you're dying for the gift
of life that the universe has given to
you
and i find that to be amazing and that
for them would be a mark of a life that
was well well lived and that was the
whole point of philosophy is to
live a life that's truly worth living so
if you
felt a deep sense of regret on your
deathbed that would probably mean that
you felt that you had made some very
serious errors in your life um another
idea that i think is very important for
people today
um that comes from the stoics all of the
stoics believed in this they were the
most pro-social philosophers in the
ancient world and they taught that we
should all contribute to society marcus
aurelius was obsessed with this his
meditations is
a pretty short book but he he reminds
himself like it was his personal
notebook he reminds himself 80 times to
contribute to the common good
and
and the stoics uh they didn't believe
these things
in the way that a religious person would
believe them because they were
philosophers so they always had an
argument for this and their argument was
that all people are born with the
faculty of reason which makes us
rational creatures
and it also makes us equal to one
another so
the stoics were the first philosophical
school to say that human beings were
equal to one another the idea of human
equality and it also means that because
we have this spark of reason in common
uh there's a you know universal
brotherhood or sisterhood of humanity
that we're all part of
and
uh that means we should help each other
and over the course of centuries it took
a very long time this stoic idea led to
the idea of human rights equality and
ultimately to the elimination of slavery
in some ways because the enlightenment
philosophers who were talking about
human rights
and criticizing the institution of
slavery were very familiar with these
stoic views and drew upon them
incredible historical context and some
of what we've been talking about today
is in the book breakfast with seneca a
stoic guide to the art of living we've
been speaking with the book's author
writer and philosopher david feidler
really appreciate your time today and
your insights
great it's been wonderful speaking with
you
follow us on social media interact with
the david pakman show community see
exclusive content see when we're taking
calls live and stay up to date on other
big show announcements we post daily
find us on reddit twitter instagram
facebook discord and tick tock
i don't know how many of you are old
enough to remember sarah palin sarah
palin used to be the governor of wasilla
alaska she was john mccain's
presidential running mate in 2008 had
john mccain won
sarah palin would have been a heartbeat
away from the presidency which is a very
scary thought because she is
aggressively incompetent aggres
could have been
maybe
uh i i don't think it's even close would
have been dramatically less competent
than even someone like a dan quayle
so we really dodged a bullet in terms of
sarah palin not becoming the vice
president of the united states sarah
palin
recently said she will get a covet
vaccine over her dead body meaning she
she'll die before she gets a covet
vaccine sarah palin now has coveted
um and it is uh of course raising a lot
of questions as to whether uh
what the course of the disease is going
to be
reuters reporting sarah palin's positive
covet test delays her new york times
defamation trial which is also just
hilarious sarah palin has tested
positive for the virus forcing a u.s
judge to delay her defamation trial
against the new york times
it's particularly funny that her bogus
defamation trial now gets delayed
because she has covered jury selection
was expected to start monday push back
10 days after the test results for the
57 year old palin became known she was
expected to testify in person as soon as
today tuesday u.s district judge jed
rakoff in manhattan said she is of
course unvaccinated since she has
apparently tested positive three times
i'm going to assume she is positive
palin also tested positive last march
she has been she is objected to
mandatory vaccinations it will be over
my dead body that i will have to get a
shot here is the video of sarah palin
explaining that to turning point usa's
charlie kirk
remember this
and i will it'll be over my dead body
that i'll have to get a shot
i will not do it right
crowd loves that
i won't do it and um
they better not touch my kids either
because that's that's where the
well governor some people say though i
might lose my job
i might get kicked out of school
yeah i know and um you know i think if
enough of us though
rise up and say new enough is enough
there are more of us than there are of
them okay anyway so over her dead body
she will get vaccinated let's really
hope it doesn't come to that now there's
a question as to whether she's really
unvaccinated or is claiming she is to
keep up appearances some people even
saying
i will
i will
have to get a shot over my dead body
which may be different than
i've gotten a shot by choice
but i won't get one by four so with all
these people it's like the desantis
thing were you boosted sir
well uh you know i uh got the normal
shot well so hold on are you boosted or
not no no i'm not gonna say that uh now
we could ask her but the truth is that
should really be between her and her
doctor because as you all know all of
these republicans believe that uh
medical decisions should be left to
women and their doctors when it comes to
women's health those are private matters
in which the state should have
what oh oh oh i'm sorry sorry i i now i
understand why it's so stupid to be
saying that so sarah palin has coveted
and she i guess will get a shot only
over her dead body
all right this story is really
interesting so yesterday joe biden
called fox news reporter peter ducey a
stupid son of a [ __ ]
some people say it was a hot mic that
joe biden didn't know his mic was on
it's not obvious to me i i i when you
watch the video when you listen biden's
face is right in front of a microphone
and i think it's quite plausible biden
did know that the mic was on and it sort
of like slipped out or he just didn't
care or whatever and the incident itself
is not that interesting to me but the
reaction is absolutely fascinating
because of the incredible hypocrisy that
republicans are applying so here's the
back story steve ducey is in the press
corps for fox news
his big thing is constantly trying to
ask gotcha questions of gensake and of
joe biden they're often very stupid but
it doesn't really matter joe biden calls
on peter ducey all the time it's known
everybody knows ducey's going to ask
adversarial questions joe biden calls on
him all the time
he hasn't tried to get him kicked out of
the press corps he hasn't tried to get
his credential removed the way donald
trump did of jim acosta and others and
so yesterday uh as steve as peter ducey
often does he yelled a question to joe
biden the question was is it a liability
to have high inflation and biden sort of
responded no it's an asset sarcastically
and said you stupid son of a [ __ ] so
let's here's the video and here's the
audio
[Music]
that's a great asset more inflation
what a stupid sound little [ __ ]
okay
what a stupid son of a [ __ ] so let's go
through this
is uh is deuce we're gonna get to glenn
greenwald in a second is ducey more or
less a [ __ ] yeah his his you know bogus
gotcha questions they're just so boring
at this point
they're they're gotchas but they fail
uh now joe biden was out of line when it
comes to decorum this is not how a
president should speak to members of the
press uh i agree with the assessment of
ducey as uh basically being a [ __ ]
he's annoying he's just trying to get
gotchas and sound bites and whatever
but when i would criticize donald trump
and say that's not how you should be
treating members of the press
i i apply the exact same standard to joe
biden biden was out of line presidents
shouldn't speak like this even if it was
funny even if it was fun even if it was
a higher energy moment for biden
whatever okay so fine it should not have
spoken that way
that being said
there are people taking this incident
to suggest that the sky is falling and
that this is a dangerous attack on press
freedom one example is a guy named glenn
greenwald the gren glenn greenwald used
to do some pretty good reporting back in
the day did a lot of interesting stuff
but now
i don't know what is going on with glenn
greenwald check out this is a very
somber greenwald reporting to us that it
is a very dark dark day in america
because of what joe biden said check
this out
hello everyone this is glenn greenwald
and today is a dark and
really dangerous day for press freedom
in america a hard-working journalist
peter ducey did nothing more than go to
work today to do his job he went to the
white house to ask a question of the
most powerful political official
on the planet president biden a question
and this
is assault that was unleashed on him
okay so then he plays it that was it was
an assault
this is some of the fakest drama that i
can imagine here here's the bottom line
okay
biden was out of line
with peter ducey without a doubt
the people saying this was a dangerous
attack on freedom of the press that this
was an assault
when there has been no contempt for
the media from joe biden during his
presidency
these very same people i'm not talking
about greenwald now but just the people
look at twitter right the very same
people losing their minds over what joe
biden said were silent during the trump
administration when trump mocked a
disabled reporter they were silent when
trump attacked jim acosta and had him
banned and when he called chuck todd a
[ __ ] and all these different things
biden was out of line
but biden called ducey to apologize
trump never apologized to the reporters
he mistreated
look at how peter ducey even describes
the conversation
uh after
years of clips of the president and i
kind of mixing it up on the campaign
trail and during the transition and here
at the white house
uh within about an hour of that exchange
he called my cell phone
and uh he said it's nothing personal pal
and we
went back and forth and we were talking
about i
just kind of
moving moving forward and i made sure to
tell him that i'm always going to try to
ask something
different than what everybody else is
asking and uh he said you've got to
and that's a quote from the president
does that sound like donald trump does
that prove to us that this was a dark
and dangerous day in america
no come on guys
biden immediately apologized trump would
never apologize biden has never
advocated
for nor has he tried to ban peter ducey
from the press briefings in fact he
calls on him almost every briefing trump
took away jim acosta's press credential
joe biden has never broadly called
adversarial media
the enemy of the people he's never
called the media the enemy of the people
trump called the the enemy referred to
adversarial media as the enemy of the
people there is no similarity between
this and trump biden was out of line i
apply the same standard to biden and
trump on how they talk to members of the
media biden apologized
and everything about the context is
completely different
um give me a break guys it's it's hard
to even take seriously the videos like
that from glenn greenwald when what the
relationship has been with the biden
administration in the media is a hundred
and eighty degrees different from what
it was under trump if you disagree with
me let me know but it's uh it's just
pathetic opportunism that we are seeing
here we have a voicemail number that
number is 2192 david p
here is a voicemail from again someone
who completely misunderstood everything
i've said
i just i i must really be a terrible
communicator let's listen
well david i really feel bad for you
right there when you describe the
options that you're exploring that last
one with poland and belarus that sounds
like the long shot
of the three
how have you considered a fourth option
maybe somewhere in spain or italy oh god
since you're fluent in spanish
and other spanish speakers in italy
uh
why not spain italy have you thought
about that
i never said that moving to poland or
belarus is anywhere on my list when
someone said david what's your escape
plan if the u.s becomes authoritarian i
explained
because i was born in argentina i can go
back to argentina anytime that's an
option
i could go to israel and i believe it's
within about a year i could get
citizenship there
the third option i mentioned is because
i have lineage to poland family that
fled poland before the holocaust there
is a law
which if you can prove that lineage
you can get a european passport okay i
explained the part of poland my family
was from is now belarus so
i'm not thinking of moving to belarus or
poland i was explaining that the
documents i need might be in what is now
belarus or they might be in what is now
poland but the point would be just to
get the european passport and with that
i would have my pick and and yes of
course i would probably end up either in
spain because i speak spanish in france
my friends my french is good enough and
i really like france
sure italy but but i'm i'm not thinking
of moving to poland and certainly not
thinking of moving to belarus which is
not even i wouldn't even be able to
because it's a totally totally different
thing
uh i hope i hope i've been more clear
today
we have a great bonus show for you today
israeli data suggests a fourth covet
shot is unlikely for most people now the
important thing is a fourth one of the
one we have
what about an omicron shot that's a
different story and we're going to talk
about that on today's bonus show number
two
the us supreme court is going to be
hearing a challenge to race conscious
college admissions these are elements of
affirmative action we're going to talk
about a big big case
and lastly it shouldn't surprise us
after republicans all voted against joe
biden's covet stimulus they took credit
for getting people money
and after voting against joe biden and
democrats infrastructure bill they are
now taking credit for that
infrastructure bill predictable all on
today's bonus show sign up at
joinpackman.com to get instant access